slimeroni the one and only
can we figure out how we got to
slimeroni as the rap name where did we
how do we land here yeah so slime my
homies gave me that name and the aroni
is short for Tenderoni so you're are you
anyone's Tenderoni currently no no no no
no no no
no I figured like maybe you're really
into macaroni passionately about that or
oh yeah I got a song come back around it
so but I'm I'm the macaroni you know
what I'm saying I don't feel what you're
saying elaborate being a Mac is like I
got the juice I got you got the juice
you know do you know how to make
macaroni yeah like is it good though
yeah
give me your recipe how do we do we got
the metal we got the metal tray okay how
many layers of cheese what are we doing
do five layer cheese okay got some
butter got the noodles get the milk yeah
what else you need in there like
[__] I forgot
how to make this [__] but yeah yeah I
get what I'm saying so you you put your
Mac and Cheese against most people's
would you say I mean I don't know
I don't I don't think so I mean I could
cook but I ain't gonna say I'm just like
can I just hear you say music
music wow
I thought you were about to hit me with
that Mercy nah I thought she was going
straight to that music
see Memphis got different sides so like
we all kind of talk different everybody
from every side that I've I've talked to
everyone's people who are Ops with each
other people everyone says music you're
the only person from Memphis that said
music
though I don't even say music anymore I
use the same music I do I love it yeah
I'm like kind of envious of your guys's
accent because I think it's amazing
thank you yeah shout out to Memphis it's
a great place